all right so tony
gayle anthony i do a hidden treasure
chest
filled with more than one million
dollars in golden jewels has been found
in the rocky mountains
after a decade-long search art and
antiquities collector forrest fenn who
hit the stash says
a treasure hunter located the chest a
few days ago
he posted clues to the treasure's
location online
and in a poem that was published in his
2010 autobiography
the thrill of the chase now five years
ago on cbs sunday morning despite our
barry peterson's
deep and probing questions fenn remained
tight-lipped
the only way that i could prove to you
that
that the treasure is hidden is to take
you there
and what are my chances that you were
going to do that there's an old saying
two people can keep a secret if one of
them is dead
so anthony fenn estimates 350 000 people
have searched
for the treasure over 10 years but i was
inspired to treasure hunting
long before fenn's book after watching
the classic r gang short mama's little
pirate remember the one where
spanky and the gang find the treasure
and golden jewels look at little spanky
and scotty there
hey you know what guys i actually have
some good news for would-be treasure
hunters
i were i wrote the first big national
article about forrest fenn spent months
on it spent a week with forrest fenn
himself
and i got to tell you i do not believe
that that treasure has been found until
forrest fenn
who knows how to speak a story knows how
to manipulate the media
until we see a picture i do not believe
it forest
i know you you know me i want to see a
picture my friend
i stand by it all right vlad thank you
very much